janry 2017 reports that Russian forces
have entered the Baltics Vladimir Putin
is using military muscle to test
America's new president
US Marines are sent to counter the
threat on behalf of NATO and a drawn
into heavy skirmishing this is an
exercise but with relations between
Russia and the West going from bad to
worse there's a new sense of urgency and
a fear of this happening for real this
year we more openly spose speak about
who is this threat and how we have to
resist react on this threat what
specifically is the threat you think the
strattice is so much as our military
forces near the eastern border from
Russian side this activities and
escalation this el pastor lost this
location of a huge number of soldiers
nurses it east borders
us paratroopers prepare to drop 150
miles from the Russian border in the
skies over Latvia
while they drill with allies rhetoric in
their presidential election back home
raises doubts about NATO that hangover
it's more vulnerable members as tensions
with Russia continue to build we always
train with a sense of urgency they
always look to the to the future and the
futures on unknown right the features
unwritten and so when we train we make
it as tough and as realistic as we can
every time Russia and its leader haunt
the Baltics countries like Latvia still
trying to emerge from decades of Soviet
domination the last Cold War cast long
shadows here still and now a second one
looms large former foreign minister
Sandra kinetic signed Latvia up to both
NATO and EU membership she says the
world needs to wake up to the threat
posed by Russia I think it is very
dangerous because it is unpredictable as
a president putin is unpredictable he is
not guided by pragmatic political
analysis how worried should we be by
Russia do you think i would say that we
have to be very alerted but we have to
be vigilant and we have to be smart and
resilient and if we're not what happens
then
god knows what happens then
Russia's new posturing beyond its
borders and fears of a second Cold War
are the only challenges for America's
new president China's expanding its
military and territory north korea
aggressively pursuing nuclear weapons
from Libya to Yemen the Middle East is
in flames revolutions discerning into
savage civil wars huge numbers are on
the move desperate to escape chaos and
violence at home if Hillary Clinton wins
the presidency that's the world she
inherits from Barack Obama but from what
she's saying on the campaign trail she's
not planning any major shifts in foreign
policy people around the world follow
our presidential campaigns so closely
trying to get hints about what we will
do can they rely on us with the
Americans again lead the world that's
what is at stake the man who led the
West's most powerful alliance through
most of the Obama presidency says his
successor will need to be different I
think President Obama has been too
reluctant to use military force or
threatened to use military force to
prevent conflicts in the world so after
this period of reluctance we need more
American interventionism actually we
need America as the world's policeman we
need determined American global
leadership it is not possible though for
superpowers simply to retire and give up
on being a su papa no superpowers don't
get to retire
but in this election millions of
Americans have shown their support for a
candidate who wants the u.s. to withdraw
more and intervene less and who's
question its ties with old allies
in a year of global turmoil some of the
architecture of our post-war world order
has already begun to crumble the
rhetoric in America's election hasn't
helped this is a house of commons
library that provides MPs with
independent research and where records
of all the nations treaties are kept
I've come to find Parliament's copy of
the north atlantic treaty signed in 1949
for almost seven decades the agreement
recorded in these pages had helped
guarantee our peace and security the key
part of the treaty is article 5 the
parties agree that an armed attack
against one or more of them in Europe or
North America shall be considered an
attack against them all it's a principle
of all for one and one for all Donald
Trump through that principle into doubt
threatening to withdraw America's
automatic support for its allies we have
spent trillions of dollars over time on
planes missiles ships equipment building
up our military to provide a strong
defense for Europe and Asia the
countries we are defending must pay for
the cost of this defense and if not the
US must be prepared to let these
countries defend themselves it could be
that he puts a nail into the coffin of
the transatlantic alliance that is
possible so Christopher mayor was the
UK's man in Washington in the bush years
at the height of the war on terror the
Republican nominee he says has
undermined NATO he has already suggested
that article 5 of the NATO treaty the
one that says if a member state is
attacked then all the other members of
the Alliance are duty-bound to come to
the assistance of that state he has
already said of that state in his view
is not paying its dues into the NATO
budget then article 5 will be suspended
that is truly a nail in the coffin of
the post-second World War international
or
whoever wins this election has lasting
damage already been done by this
campaign to the way America is seen
around the world and the way it projects
its power and as that already undermined
global stability it says to my mind that
America's politics has gone very very
wrong veteran observers of American
politics looking on in horror or in
little doubt I don't think we've ever
seen a candidate emerging of this kind
in the United States actually really
ever certainly since it's been a great
power and I think we are right to be
worried about the potential implications
of this transformation of the basis of
American democracy in Washington the
ghosts of the country's great past are
looking down on this election while
Americans wonder if they'll ever see
their like again we appreciate greatness
in many other aspects of the American
Enterprise on the athletic field in
Hollywood and Broadway Pulitzer Prize
winners Nobel laureates Bob Dylan we
have a hard time appreciating greatness
in our political culture the reason is
simple we don't see it anymore Americans
have always believed that their form of
government is exceptional Abraham
Lincoln thought it was worth fighting a
civil war form they believe that their
kind of democracy isn't just the best
way of running their own country but
should be an example for others to
follow an inspiration to the world this
election has been anything but and
ultimately that may be the biggest
challenge for whoever is sworn in here
on Capitol Hill as the 45th president
can they restore America's belief in
itself and the world's faith in America
you